If you’ve watched any number of nature documentaries,
you’ve probably seen some variation on this scene.
In place of ciliates, you might see a lion
stalking its prey, or a shark lunging for
its next meal.
The tension builds, the motion of spring loaded
muscles matched by creeping music as the predator
waits for its moment to strike.
Sometimes the outcome is similar to this feeding
frenzy.
But other times, the kindly voice of an elderly
narrator assures you that the prey has escaped.
All is well...this time.
The microcosmos is filled with its own versions
of these tales of predation and survival.
This isn’t a world built on nocturnal predators
or camouflage that shields predator and prey alike.
These are hunters who have to resort to other
methods to find their food, like this lacrymaria’s
sweeping approach to the hunt.
While this protist may look delicate, it is
an incredibly successful hunter.
It can extend the tip of its neck out to seven
times the length of its body, and then retract
it back in a matter of seconds, and it uses
this motion to seek out its prey.
Each time the lacrymaria sticks its head out, what it’s really doing is gambling.
It’s playing the odds that as it whips around,
it’ll make contact with food, and it can
play this game for minutes and minutes, using
the dense cilia on its head to search until,
like this lucky lacrymaria, an unfortunate
ciliate comes into contact and quickly becomes prey.
But not all threats in the microcosmos move
so quickly.
Sometimes, it's the stationary organisms you
have to look out for.
Collothecas, for example, are a type of rotifer
that are sessile, meaning they do not move around.
Instead, it attaches its foot to a surface
and just waits, letting its exceptionally
long cilia hang out like cat's whiskers to
draw in food.
And from this angle, the rotifer seems to
make catching food look easy, like it just
needs to sit around and wait for a flagellate
to stroll into its mouth.
From the flagellate’s perspective, the situation
is a little more dire.
It was just casually living its life one second, and then trapped in the belly of a rotifer the next.
Take a wrong turn in the microcosmos, and
you might find yourself facing other threats
as well, not just at the hands of a predator.
This ciliate came from a lake that was nearly
frozen, and as we prepared it for the microscope,
the organism had to contend with a very rapid
change in temperature.
Unable to withstand that change in its surroundings,
the ciliate died, its membrane rupturing and
emptying out.
All of that order, immediately returned to
disorder.
This other ciliate was able to survive the
initial temperature shock that took its neighbor.
But as it nears the spilled contents of the
dying ciliate, the healthy one suddenly becomes
much less healthy.
And it too bursts.
We've seen this before on our channel, and
it still remains a mystery no matter how many
times we watch an organism experience this
strange, contagious death.
Perhaps there was a change in osmotic pressure
around the first dying ciliate, which would
have then damaged the membrane of the healthy
one wandering by.
But some threats can be anticipated.
This homalozoon is a single-celled hunter,
and it is on the prowl, searching for something
delicious to eat in a veritable buffet of
paramecium.
And when one potential prey comes near, the
homalozoon winds up, using structures on its
ectoplasm called extrusomes that act like
harpoons to pierce their target and inject
toxins into them.
But where you might expect a victorious hunter,
this homalozoon recoils back.
It all happens so quickly, it’s hard for
us to see exactly what’s going on.
It turns out that the homalozoon was not the
only organism coming into battle armed.
The paramecium had its own defenses too, a
4 micron long structure called a trichocyst
that can extend to a longer length in a matter
of milliseconds in response to some kind of
stimulus---like another organism trying to
injure it.
The homalozoon is able to get its attack in,
stunning the paramecium.
But it is also left confused by the paramecium’s
response, as it begins nibbling away on those
protective trichocysts instead of the delicious
microbe itself.
And in the meantime, the paramecium is able
to recover and escape… this time.
But sometimes, these natural protections can
fail you.
Testate amoebas form protection out of bits
of sand from their environment, sticking them
together with an adhesive to form a shell.
It’s difficult for us to get a good image
of this shell, but it’s that dark shape
moving through the frame.
And like any shell, it’s great protection--as
long as you can stay inside it.
But the amoeba has things it has to do, and
that means it needs to extend its body outwards
using its pseudopodia.
And in that moment of vulnerability, the coleps
strikes.
Coleps may be tiny, but they have extrusomes
that pack quite a punch.
The toxins they inject into the amoeba do
their work quickly, tearing the pseudopodium apart.
And like a pack of scavengers following the
smell of blood in water, these coleps can
sense the dying amoeba.
They swarm around and consume the bits and
pieces, the undigested amoeba visible inside
their bodies while the shell sits uselessly
next to them.
But the microcosmos is remarkable in its resiliency.
And so let us end with this ciliate, which
has dealt with some kind of damage.
There are a number of microbes that are able
to repair themselves, some of which we’ve
talked about on this channel.
But we haven’t been able to show you one
in action.
We don’t know what caused this ciliate’s
membrane to rupture in this way, where we
can see these bits and pieces almost poking
out of it.
But as it turns and turns and waves its cilia,
we can see its membrane beginning to knit
back together until finally at the end, it
almost seems as if there was never any damage
to begin with.
The ciliate has survived this day, and all
is well, no matter what may happen tomorrow.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And if you like what we do, you should be thanking these people on the screen right now.
They are our patrons on Patreon.
I know there are some of you right now, looking at your own name.
So, thank you.
And if you want to join that wonderful group of people,
you can do that at Patreon.com/journeytomicro
If you want to see more from our Master of Microscopes James,
check out Jam & Germs on Instagram
if you want to see more from us,
you can find our channel at YouTube.com/microcosmos